hello Raymond captain wuntch good to see
you but if you're here who's guarding
Hades it's deputy chief wuntch now
unsurprisingly I've been promoted above
you and now I'm here to evaluate you
we're having a brand he retired and
moved to Charleston to be closer to his
grandchildren so much for dying at your
desk with a little dignity interesting I
will attempt to cooperate with you under
these new circumstances don't sweet-talk
me halt I gave it my best shot
let's begin spot checks are done
needless to say I'm thoroughly
underwhelmed huh from your expression I
would guessed constipated or chilly
what's amazing
we got a task force more importantly
once you got served oh my god once
sounds like lunch now this opens up so
many new avenues looks like we've both
got a pretty bad case of jerk boss yes
yours is an idiot and mine is a
fork-tongued lizard which what about the
time you destroyed my personnel file
while I was undercover what if there
been a mole you were trying to make me
disappear you embarrassed me from Derek
Jeter you embarrassed yourself in front
of Derek Jeter you're like the League of
Nations in 36 just hoping the Abyssinian
crisis resolves itself that's the lesson
you draw from the fall of Addis Ababa
Raymond you sound so naive and you sound
just like Victor Emmanuel the third I
have no idea who's winning I am
wuntch hello raymond you're looking old
and sickly so nice of you to greet us
Madeline I thought surely you'd still be
crushed under that house in Munchkinland
sticks and stones Raymond describing
your breakfast sergeant as long as I'm
asking for word madeline wuntch can say
no to anything may I
those are my tissues Raymond if you were
planning on sneezing you should have
brought your own sir she's a deputy
teeth I'm sure she wants what's best for
the community she doesn't care about the
community she only cares about defeating
me this is war sergeant the war on lunch
oh good you've named it so I've been
planning how to zing Madeline when she
puts the medal on I have the perfect
line once time is over so it's a play on
lunchtime
yes devastating burn sir hello deputy
chief wuntch you've aged how'd it go
with Miller fantastic you love me I
would give you more details but someone
just came in to try and find her
Dalmatian coat hello Raymond Madeline I
wondered why all the birds that suddenly
stopped singing what brings you here I
heard you were under investigation by
internal affairs didn't want to miss
that so much time with your here to the
pavement it's a pity a truck hasn't run
over your head ah there it is a
shriveled husk of Raymond Holt look Gina
is that a talking raisin enough foreplay
wow you were right it was one mistake
you think that semicolon was a mistake
no it was a juicy piece of bait and she
unhinged her jaw and swallowed it whole
yes I should be the bigger person
shouldn't be hard given that methods not
technically a person deputy chief wuntch
is here to see you oh please they Diaz I
need a witness in case her head starts
spinning around hoarse she turns into a
she-wolf hmm an embarrassing blight
growing right under your nose not unlike
that mustache you had when we first met
that moustache was era-appropriate
you're going to leave my precinct and my
task force alone or else you were
wuntch meet you sure you want to go with
that one
absolutely it's hilarious now right
Raymond Madeline you're one go ahead and
gloat you toad thank you for this honor
deputy chief noh okay
you're welcome once time is over both
ways
no regrets unfortunately because this
case has turned out to be important that
she's gone madeline wuntch has her
hindquarters pointed right at it I'm a
front runner for a job in the Boston PD
Boston but it's so close to Salem you do
know what they do the witches up there
don't you this is amazing she's the
devil and you don't dance with the devil
because you get burned also because in
Madeline's case she has no rhythm and
her hands are like little rat claws I've
come to ask for your help the
Commissioner will be moment savored so
where were we so here's how I see this
going down you plead for your job back I
refuse you start weeping like a war
Widow does that sound about right
don't count your gross fish babies
before they're hatched Madeleine how did
you get this hello Raymond how do you
like my new office 20th floor yes I
never thought I'd see you this high
without a broom under you enough
niceties have a seat I got her a parting
gift tickets to wicked in Boston she's
moving to a second-class City and I
wanted to rub her nose in it enjoy the
understudies Madeline have fun watching
some chubby Chenoweth knockoff warble
her way through popular so you've got an
audience for this little stunt
yes well who wouldn't want to see a man
fight a crocodile
I'm gonna call Commissioner sheesh I
know you never would have recommended me
for that Boston Post if deep down you
didn't think I deserve the job
what uh my lady left me my lady stayed
come on sir focus on the good you can
hold your head up you took the high road
with wuntch not entirely when I was
alone in our office I changed her
autocorrect now when she types of lunch
it gets replaced with but I'm not going
anywhere
Madeline's not some invincible succubus
she's a regular succubus so she can't be
defeated we just need to find the letter
Madeline thank you for coming
Raymond oh is the pleasure to call on a
vanquished foe I feel like Jackie
joyner-kersee congratulating one of the
other slower runners buckle up it's
gonna be a hell of a ride Curtis it I'm
sure you'd like to take some weight off
your cloven hooves calling me the devil
how original Raymond actually I was
calling you a goat the goat you have
until tomorrow you grackle
you came to me to ask for help shows how
much you've matured you know it all
shows how much you matured you with a
face no I know why you referred to this
as a suicide scrubber alter because I
already want to kill myself why don't
you wait a week you probably died of old
age the only way I'm gonna die as if you
touch me with one of your bony fingers
and drag me across the river Styx
rebirth a wonderful very creative look
John Kelly has to be stopped he's spying
on civilians it's unconstitutional and
it's wrong please do you think any one
of these jackals cares about what's
right or wrong
I'll help see sir there is good in every
person I want to be known as for selfish
reasons why would you want that to be
now because I never miss CJ before and I
want my thing to help cool it's working
I mean I love how you're taking over the
room
you know I actually wouldn't mind
getting rid of John Kelly either and
that makes up so many dumb rules he told
me I couldn't eat raw chicken and you
think a new Commissioner he's already on
board so yes a new commissioner would
let you eat raw chicken for whatever
reason it's healthier it sure is see Jan
what do you hope to get out of this
Madeline let me guess revenge on Dorothy
for killing your sister I want the same
as you Raymond I think what John Kelly
is doing is terrible yes well said lunch
so we're all on board this is exciting
let's bring it in huh
Suicide Squad on three ready one two
don't touch other Jews have this it is
sticky that might be me I ate a popsicle
early it's probably Madeline cockroaches
release of mucus like secretion the
point is without any good leads Kelly
will give the order to use the Stingray
an order that we will record thanks to
our very own madeline wuntch she's not
possible Kelly won't tell me anything
you won't even meet with me perhaps you
can sneak in disguised as an old leather
chair will you calm down
she works at one Police Plaza all you
have to do is run into it mr. Kelly no
Madeline I didn't see you there I
thought you were an old leather chair
he's not gonna say that but you're worse
than the vulture oh goody gumdrops but
do we even need her what does she bring
to the table thirty years of police
experience I have 33 I earned a police
combat from I have a Medal of Honor I
own the record for most arrests as a
uniformed officer an NYPD history you
got me there of course I never spent
much time in uniform because I was
promoted to detective after one month
they're not allowed to do that it's
against the rule it's also against the
rules that let a pile of worms wear a
uniform and yet here you stay okay just
stop how do we get close enough without
attracting attention good dance you must
know some moves you were mentioned by
name in the Monster Mash is fine but on
two conditions we stay at least four
inches apart at all times and you tuck
your tail back into your pants so I
don't trip on you move well must be all
the extra legs you crab did you find
miss exhausting thinking of fresh
insults not at all you coffin cave mold
beetle
I meant our relationship aren't you
tired of the rivalry we fight and we
fight and nothing changes oh we're
really not so different I suppose we
were close once remember
Brighton Beach twelve hundred kilos of
heroin and your fan dance upwards on the
largest drug bust an NYPD history pulled
off by the most unlikely duo a woman the
gay black detective no I meant a human
and a lot of Jack O'Lantern
you